pour certains néo ruraux souvent le
village idéal c'est ça le silence pour
compagnon mais un saint maurice sur
aveyron à ce silence justement depuis
que l'église a perdu sa voix est
déprimant c'est merveilleux d'entendre à
longueur de journée l'horloge qui nous
rythme notre vie parce qu'on en a besoin
on va trop vite trop vite hélas et c'est
vraiment bénéfique même en ce sens calme
apaisé quand on se dit ah bon et dès 11h
ah bon il est midi ça y est c'est
l'angélus et bosses et nous avons fait
notre notre journée le soir a fait taire
quatre ans sans le son des cloches c'est
trop alors pour pousser un peu le maire
a trouvé une solution
ils sont 150 à avoir signé la pétition
pour entendre à nouveau sonner le
clocher un saint maurice sur aveyron une
campagne aseptisé non merci
arrêtez les cloches pour le bien-être
entre guillemets de certaines personnes
c'est un peu dommage on a rencontré
personne qui nous offre qui nous a
opposé vraiment un refus de signer la
pétition pour ça revienne pas du tout
tout ce qui est tout ce qui rythme la
vie du village et rythmé par la vie des
cloches une initiative qui visiblement
ne gêne pas les deals un village c'est
un tout
chaque élément il est indispensable et
je comprends parfaitement que les
commerces qui sont le pouls de
l'activité du village l'école qui en est
le coeur l'église
tout cela participe de la vie du village
de son animation et donne je dirai tout
là tout le plaisir de vivre de bien
vivre dans un village comme le nôtre
la mairie a déboursé un peu moins de
2000 euros pour un nouveau moteur qui
sera installé dans moins d'un mois les
cloches sonneront à nouveau jour et nuit
en attendant certains ne peuvent plus
attendre
justement
[Musique]